check check check check very loud what
up all right check it
what's up fool what's a full podcast
welcome to the worst a full podcast
Felipe Esparza is right here man back
Wednesday afternoon if you're watching
it live on YouTube so everybody else is
watching it on or listening to it on
Monday Friday or today is your first
time here and we're in our 1,000 episode
and you bet you're here at 201 stop or
never too late
right here I probably speak to the
future bro that's what I'm talking about
I'll give me the message here bro for
the person who just got here time work
blessing I know there's something people
tell me bro man I'm barely in episode 10
bro hit me we got a 200 commitment
you're on that hole so we will just get
high or they get drunk or they go on a
17-hour flight and they go through like
savage episode you big a podcast no not
really
what's your part can you listen to
besides yeah man I dude I haven't
listened to podcast a lot lately like
glass I used to listen to it in the
beginning like probably like three years
ago hardcore a bunch away here bro yeah
bunch of [ __ ] skate legend
extraordinaire thank you very much for
popping in dog when he said he was the
first Louis kid no person skater I
thought it was [ __ ] it was just him
and we member thought we went well first
I beat him yes we're always like [ __ ]
we were always around the same time and
we men's of a good friend of mine I
believe that I with the company I skated
for III came out with the first cuz you
uh you were in big brother magazine back
in the day I was he was he was in big
brother magazine - it was kind of like
our introduction to the skateboard world
together and we just kind of went our
own separate ways I was I feel that I
was more in the skateboard world than
the skateboard loop were as he took off
with the skateboarding but also fell
into the Jackass crew and they kind of
went more mainstream yeah a little
cultural things yeah and it did really
well for him so I'm stoked for him okay
now he owns taco stands yeah we man's
chronic tacos yes Santa Monica somewhere
right I think he just partnered up with
him and like this they would add his
name on there and his face and it's
pretty what happened with Trejo - right
he isn't he's not making those tacos I
know his recipes I think he runs the
place we went there - Danny Trejo day
like 12 years ago dogs I didn't see him
making tacos so donut told me no bro no
nose I created some kind of vegan taco
or something because people were going
to his taco spot and there was no choice
in that matter and he created something
dope that people are really loving I
haven't tried it yet but yeah then a
channel bro has his old school homey as
if his homey right back over workers his
homey homey his homey son is the
assistant he's the one who's coming back
a carefully bit number yeah he sent
Danny sent that guy over to Felipe
portal oh man he's like look at his now
thank you thank you thank you everybody
everybody everybody who showed up to the
Mexican Independence Easter Day Parade
2019 man with championship of chapter
and heavyweight champion of the world
Andy Reese at the Grand Marshal oh yeah
and SuperSonics
I guess media they were there
controlling [ __ ] controlling
people in charge I don't know who
they're really in charge out there but a
lot of people barrel King in the way
before we get to the parade Pancho the
retailer tip dog first of all man I
really care about taking pony with these
[ __ ] bro like I don't care have
a meeting later on yeah so I don't want
to come like all crazy but sometimes you
know you want your photo me with the
phone but I don't know what I wouldn't
like so then my ponies tells me a you
want a photo with Andy
yeah yeah I don't think there's
scream his name in front of my face I
think a father mother brother and I mean
I could have done that yeah but not my
publicist boat to be the end / - look
you know the bad people bro - the bad
people for you like so the 100 there and
you know what I'm Ernie G can't come in
do you have a fourth she's the one that
has a photo I [ __ ] you don't
want inside right basically like if I
ever say something really nasty or not -
on Twitter
no come on and say something like waffle
if it was hacked an hour ago I missed
the show you know or something
Filipa had a flu yeah I'll never you
know that people would ask question what
happened a Philippe you know I'll spin
it for you no spinning over no Ashley
Filippo's lay down under a lot of
pressure with traveling a lot with this
podcast and the meetings that getting
around to do wrong there fixing mistakes
so ambien you know they heard this life
so many times that they believe it now I
thank you extraordinary like like I put
a shirt up our publicist could fix
already lags career right away bro come
first of all he'll be with a Latino
nobody no I never heard him you can
restore his career oh yeah think
basically what a person should do that
you know like if you come out of the
[ __ ] like really bad just say you're
a comic that are you you're done was
killing a black audience so they only
know you there yeah you know the average
Joe who goes to like gay relationship my
name might never heard of him
my daughter but not everybody knows them
so he could restore his career bro like
it mean you know the pattern like a good
policies you know like the one we have
Wendy you know ever Annika though tell
you like this bro listen man um it's
time for you to make a change
you've been this crazy [ __ ] your
whole life you're [ __ ] 45 now you
ain't no sweet poppy man the guns up you
know [ __ ] you maybe you should let that
beer get group maybe
there be no grave and start playing
state no dad Rose you know nobody's
looking at a 45 year old guy who's 30
but everybody million 45 being the farms
grow be together get the chicks 45 is
that bad though here in Los Angeles it's
like there's a new 20 right yeah it's
like 30 Lady Cho people just think it's
weird I interview for MTV today's or
somebody that's kind of like it 21 but
they look older in u.s. you take it too
many Molly's there's a lot of those
fools like sitting in the Sun just
getting leathery skin and madly no first
I would you get to bow you can't fix
stuff like you know we have it on video
like Ben Affleck crying a
jack-in-the-box role now it feels good
the way I would have fixed that would
listen man
he's been dying for a [ __ ] jumbo jack
for three days
Lokar beans a good commercial Popeye
further ahead of turkey burger burgers
and chick-fil-a's closed early Sunday so
he's crying cause worth jack-in-the-box
jack-in-the-box reminds him that one
time if that be his dad's inside that
jacket by himself
you make it so long that people start
reading it reading it it forget what
really happened that happened to me I
understand like you know but that's the
last Rob Rochas you know you couldn't
see you showing up at what time they'll
never see the [ __ ] up at me you know
next supersonic Michael I was like you
know you know when he's been dehydrated
here to a 13 hour flight from people the
waters or thought she's all [ __ ] up
the bathrooms are broken the plane
little were Flint Michigan you knows bad
oh [ __ ] John yes but
you know water looking at Road America
[ __ ] deer hunter GI JD he came in
here like a soldier with squirts and
water supporting to do or a buy sell or
Mexican what's that bro I used to put
salt in my squirt hmm a little bit of
salt
you love sad yeah I think that was
probably like them in your Pepsi - no I
grew up with hillbillies though put
peanuts and also salt and a little bit
of not bad
but then I heard that it was a tex-mex
in Chile where I come for everyone like
I I can literally which will beat you in
Chile every everyone likes like with
salad with lettuce everything is lemon
and salt lemon and salt lemon with
anything it's definitely a lot yeah also
matter anybody who's half Latino who be
realized for the heat hanging around
with Latino for the first time like
somebody who grew up half white don't
have why I'm Mexican but his whole life
been white people white people that he
grew my mac and cheese in hot dog but
now he shows up you know ain't no
Mexican for the first time real mess
back to his release who's they are were
born in Mexico food they were not born
in Mexico he's whistle the other half
that [ __ ] will put what about
you on everything time for the first
time he realized he just a party where
everywhere he'll put lemon on everything
down for us to live with a mohawk on it
that there's pasta it could be it could
be it changes the flavor to everything
jalapeno though that little tree
also for shout out man yeah go for it
let's segue somewhere else get back to
the Easter Day parade today first of all
my leg like also a public good publicist
audio ads will be on time right yeah
I'll be on time bro
I began I guess they're probably like I
get there bro like right there bro on
the dot and [ __ ] it and when I get those
shits doing ready so don't matter the
people just want to see your face bro
they know that she's gonna start in two
hours but they don't want to be worried
about you're worried about this [ __ ]
floated on this story card bro downing
you're good you're good here bro you
stay under that [ __ ] tent [ __ ] you're
gonna wake up my dad you babbling right
now there now you're matching he's gonna
be alright but what I like bro is that
so it's a free food broad you know even
though I'm vegan but I was like ah were
some good food more yeah I was their
sponsor Eamon and they were making match
oh I don't what the hell they're making
but they don't like carnita the Judi so
I guess so
you you you like vegan tacos in Brook
yeah I like vegan tacos - now I have a
question for you in a sense of like
vegan tacos like there's the potatoes
the the potato tacos you know that you
can get them like we're like they're
like homestyle potatoes or and then I've
also gotten tacos like vegan tacos that
are mashed potatoes I like the home
style potato tacos better I'm not
digging the mashed potatoes how about
you guys huh do you know everything
Chino the hood you like no that's just
what I like I've had different choices
that I'm like yeah my mom would make my
talk with a pop-up tacos if some beef I
will just potato bro it's just you get
so let's go in there bro
you like the beach get mashed or in a
match in a [ __ ] of what the loo you
know or mast or my hand or funky in the
blender
oh no by hands [ __ ] blender I don't
want puree that makes it like that like
a smoothie it's two black beans that's
[ __ ] you know that's 600 problem life
eating you throw strong that
[ __ ] brother I had a little milk
but they are little [ __ ] your bottle of
milk but instead of no we have beans and
what they just had to make the hole no
hell no no I gave him the water bro like
available yeah they [ __ ] other than
oh yeah you know like the ones that come
on us too but they give a loop a little
brother in our way dude you know what
though if you ever have vegan meringue
it's made out of aqua fafa which is the
bean juice from garbanzo beans
yeah if you ever have to fruit juice
ring you not I mean
so vegan meringue there's you can't make
because there's no eggs
it's made with that it's called aqua
father but it's it's flavored
differently but I just always think of
bean juice I can't drink that
so speaking of well we're there at the
[ __ ] parade we get there bro and the
[ __ ] my car that theory how the car
hit there I like the large not there
what happened on are you shoot up little
wrong bro
I thought you're gonna say you start
walking everybody wants their interest
I'm sad water miracle I got like a steak
bed truck and made up her own little
[ __ ] floats
she had a curve crew holding it where's
Lee Harvey Oswald I'm sorry Bob room
father looks the same but just older
santoor yeah bro who let that movie bro
up up but you should do a sketch
together bro sad whenever mom like Bruce
Willis in that movie bro looper bro hell
yeah bro lupa that was bloody bad I'll
be 40 they're both right there somebody
shows up I never got my flyers well you
got your tummy tuck on anyway so being
out at the large or in the [ __ ] spit
these to have a champion bro [ __ ]
blast team bro you [ __ ] by Silas have
a six-pack of beer and he runs up to the
car and give out of the large water all
perfect drink and drive is now we were
we were the first float car ever in pure
a history to get pulled over for DUI and
whatever level are brought here to go
that [ __ ] my own floor brother beat
him with a brick Mexicans a little a
mighty Norway I thought you and say they
empowered the float or something you
know get some hilarious huh what do I
don't know what happened but um we're
driving a bunch of people right up to
the truck the car man
and then we were left behind I mean we
were lagging bro we were let the car
from [ __ ] you out of my house but that's
because everybody was bobbing you guys
right you have you're stopping us
but they will remember notes and again
also negate of any reasons is photograph
I don't know what happens if I'm
full-blown like I got big popular soft
it is just disappeared are like God and
then I'm shut out to when they manage to
go look for it
this [ __ ] lady over there five
minutes one of those people that were
even though she were to she said it is
your phone of course this one and there
are thousands of people yeah so I told
her thank you bye blah blah which is
gracias
she is your but this Instagram I'm so
glad if you give on your phone as soon
as it like as soon as you dropped it or
whatever I started right away I give it
to you
hey that's good enough for free tickets
to the life [ __ ] your wallet bro I'm
like you don't bring up your mom man but
you're just too worried a and that
booking is worth more than anything
manager like out of you live you if you
were to lose your notes or anybody that
were so taking notes would lose their
[ __ ] and they work with anyone our
somebody brings it back it has
recordings of all your suits yeah I
always feel bad for the people I mean I
don't know if you guys have it but the
people that have this don't work board
but they also have their wallet attached
to their phone so you're done if you
lose all the credit card yeah the credit
card everything is on now I can't cuz
eight someone took my identity it was
telling a bug let's get back to that
[ __ ] your bean juice bro knows right
yeah if it's a necessity that's why you
gotta get it you but I just can't see
that we had other [ __ ] - [ __ ]
kool-aid yeah but you're also you know
like you would never think like if if
you the first time you tried it like
that my wife's parents came out here and
they're like white from Buffalo New York
they've never tried our China and when
they were trying to explain like what it
was they're like I don't know it sounds
weird like rice Jews like I don't think
so and then they tried it and they loved
it
I'm thinking like the same thing with
like what you're talking about it could
probably be pretty good for you if you
gave it a chance but like what he's
talking about
that sounds awful yeah and then topples
I'm gonna give the baby a kid like empty
your coke in a bottle if I do my little
brother was my little brother had a [ __ ]
you know nah a little Baba [ __ ]
little bottle full of beans bro like you
know that bees bros that you know oh
yeah the cheese month with little kiss
on there - bro I should have like a [ __ ]
it's like a bimbo Barbara Poppe drama
beans like we had I don't know she'd
want to buy I guess you know she wasn't
down for a little juror baby
I seen a bunch of my brother and I never
mean I never bought it through the gate
oh my god
don't take their pecker out through the
gate like their girlfriends or wives at
the time would suck the outer people
know and then like they'll bring other
girlfriends out and it's funny because
then they set up another perimeter gate
so you couldn't do that [ __ ] anymore
I've ever heard that is really true
that's [ __ ] gnarly out there bro nor
the corona brow conjugal visits in
conjugal what's up fool also saw their
arms shut up the people who I saw at the
at the place it was like an actual um
this tribal team they're like they they
actually play in old um my in-game with
them they had an actual rubber bar that
was used back in the days doing doing
doing the Mayan
a volcanic rubber ball Pro they they
actually had one man it felt like one of
those balls when you're a little kid
super balls or crazy balls that you
[ __ ] perfect like a baby the game is
soccer both with your hip yeah
no hands no hands no feet at hip how do
you get them so do you have to I think
there's one person from the outside who
throws it in right yeah and then the
rest of them play with their head it has
to just stay in
that's for salsa yeah the first version
of basketball lots of balls different
pieces from basketball so that met those
tribal food because of other ones
they're mad at this another like another
tribe or warriors that they were they
were good they live by the volcanic area
of the Mexico you know but they're all
they're black faced they kill it the
volcanic ash and they cover up their
face for war and their faces and they
look like black people but they're not
they're all Mexican it's just black
thing all mechanic does
and I thought they were blackface like
blackface to be black face but there's
the first but it was not blackface
warping basically because they would
hide in the shadows yeah but they came
out to Vegas that way no no Vegas also
you rats so they are they lived in the
mountains about they walk around the
show to battle with dead rats in their
mouths yeah scary there I went that with
the tail sticking out yeah live or
they'll hold the rat by the tail though
the first exterminators didn't work yeah
my these LA tène eggs we dig it no
history of raw for making up their own
little crumbs so there was a real deal
it was a actors people who are
descendants of those these tribes yeah
yeah
also there was Porfirio Diaz was there
Pancho Villa's that's what freaked me
that's weird I know it's East LA Mexican
Independence parade but do they do like
a reenactment cuz I was surprised at how
many conquistadors were there a shitload
of a lot of them once when I didn't know
like I mean they're people dressed up
like they're reenacting it on a float
somewhere yeah I missed I don't know boy
I didn't know was that I didn't know
that Porfirio Diaz was actually the main
guy and the Battle of Puebla and then in
Iran yeah Porfirio Diaz came in he's
part of the Mexican dependent because he
actually fired the Battle of Puebla and
whatever and he really fought but then
we keep he became a [ __ ] dictator
actually he wanted him a president for
30 years of porphyria and then that's
when Pancho beer came in so much of us
shouldn't even be at that parade but the
different revolution but the first one
was Hidalgo they [ __ ] set up there
from Spain and then it comes from botch
OVA was assassinated because he totally
everybody who thought trying to run
again read a wikipedia there's a lot of
[ __ ] that's will had a lot of enemies
though he killed a lot of people to rape
though our people yeah she killed a lot
of it's like [ __ ] a lot of people up
and then one day you're throwing out
your trash they hit you upside the head
with a pipe and shoot you in the head
it's over you ruled for a little bit but
you got slippin dog shut out to a baby
boy you're not slipping watching her
back everybody was watching this show in
the hotel big boy happy belated birthday
his birthday was actually on the day of
the parade be low-key everyone but I saw
a video of mariachis singing singing to
him and be okay to see his tears America
I grew up in Chile taught seven years
old and then I moved with my mom she
divorced my dad and we moved to the
states where to Hawaii
oh yeah so the first line look learn was
English but it was a very broken
Hawaiian pidgin English a lot like the
stuff and the kind that we'd a very
choice but it was it was cool you know
then my mom remarried and married this
guy that became my stepdad for the rest
of my life and he treated me well they
had other kids and they're you know
everyone's always like oh so they're
your half-brothers but I like to think
about mother as my real brothers just
because we have a different dad but we
grew up together yeah like we're raising
either I taught them you know so
everybody wants always bringing that
little thing oh but it's your lid no no
no so it's not your real brother it's
your half so it takes you as a [ __ ]
baby and raises you that your mom a dad
yeah that's it exactly
one real parents reflect that sometimes
gonna be a piece of [ __ ] yeah oh yeah
how did you live in Hawaii the rest of
your childhood no no I lived there for
four years and then we moved to
California when my mom remarried my dad
Robert and
you know huh oh you people and he he was
an executive chef at the Marriott
Marquis so he was a guy that they
started the kitchen created the menu God
got higher the staff got it going and
then he would get transferred yeah yeah
good good food
yeah good man the best eat grown up
eating manager said barber made man the
best thing was like leftovers thank you
oh yeah like my favorite overs and just
sure a mix would be [ __ ] yeah yeah it
was just something that you didn't think
was even good anymore and he just made
it's like one man's garbage becomes
another man's treasure
[ __ ] medley yeah bro that's how
sloppy joe would've meant it
I love sloppy joe sloppy joes with
jalapenos how about that yes delicious
but always we gotta put ketchup on the
buns okay when you pick up a skateboard
bro I picked it up like at the age of 13
and it was just something that I fell in
love with from just watching it and
something that you could do on your own
and not have someone barking orders at
you and you felt your own freedom you
got your own satisfaction from it it was
in a it was addicting to me so I just
kept going with it and my parents were
very supportive of it and kind of one
thing felt and I've met the right
friends and I was just all about
progression and getting better and
better and better and better and soon
enough I made a sponsor me video with my
friends helped and I got sponsored and
at the age of 16 and then it slowly
started to catapult me to the next level
in the next level and then traveling
around and yeah experiencing that was
awesome well your with that like when
you first started traveling around be
like a pro skater I was probably like
1996 97 97 because I graduated in 95 and
then like two years after is when I I
became a serious sponsored skater and at
the age of 21 I turned I
turn professional and that's when I just
for like 10 years straight I was just
traveling all over the world doing
competitions demos just partying with
all my friends it was great we had
Christian Hosoi and he was talking about
the partying yeah yes it definitely did
it became something that kind of almost
took over my life you know it was
skateboarding traveling wherever you
want you're giving per diem you know you
skateboard throughout the day and then
at night nightlife wherever you're at
you're like where's the party what's act
like Vikings everything was just being
thrown at me like we alcohol girl yeah
it was like skiing awesome yeah
don't forget hang around we like where
my hands like the girl thing was pretty
pretty cool in the sense that like now
like I have a different mentality
towards women but back then
skateboarding was my passion that came
first and I think girls like some girls
that like the bad boys like they they
were into it and I'm not sure if Mike so
I hooked up with a lot of girls but I'm
not sure if it was a fetish thing or it
was a bucket list thing yeah I have no
idea but I didn't give a [ __ ] so it
didn't even matter bad guy girls are
into skaters are pretty cool and it was
like sometimes like like sometimes it
was like the kid that would be at the
skate demo you know and he would bring
his older sister you know and then there
was an older sister would see like oh
you skaters horrified by all this heads
and they're like I want to meet him too
on this chick
you know what it is also though why
girls like skaters this was took me
years to figure that there's like an
alpha male thing when they're the one of
the top dogs right but there's also it's
that they they don't care about anything
else they don't even care about you it's
almost like you're being snubbed almost
by your own the oh you're the dude that
you like because all they care about is
skating like what he said like that was
my thinking about everything then it's
like skateboard I did my demo be like
hey how's it going what's up yeah I'll
be gone tomorrow thinking about skating
but afterwards I started acting about 14
years ago is my skateboard career just
it when you're a kid you know you don't
expect things to end you don't think you
don't think the rides ever stood on
pools - I scared a little I was a
transition skater I was one of those
guys that like to like to experiment
with everything I wasn't just like oh I
only need Street or at least because
then skating wouldn't be fun you would
go to a demo and it would be all ramps
there and then you can't skate it so
it's like how is that inspiring to the
kids yeah you know you need to be able
to attack any attack anything that's in
front of you and so that's kind of was
my thing like my progression the way III
kept up yeah so I I did like pools but I
wasn't I wasn't crazy like Cristiano so
I wasn't on that level he does skater
that's in prison right now for killing
his girlfriend I never met him that was
that was like the generation that's
skating the world more like the Russians
are still surfing on the ground it's
pulled and ran it was the second
generation right that was Tony Hawk
like D'Antoni like well he's still a
Jeff Phillips that was his name Keith
there was an era for skateboarding with
Christian Hosoi Tony Hawk where these
guys were the that the the starters of
it you know Tony I would join knew
nothing and then and then Street skating
came along and then and that's what we
were doing and and and for a time vert
skating completely died right yeah this
really like his career from making
thousands and thousands of dollars dead
was dead and and hey I don't know I
think that might have took a toll on
video but yeah exactly I mean all before
all that stuff Christian the soigné Tony
Hawk to have the Zephyr team like Lord's
a doctor that was more sidewalk surfin
yeah no that was like when dude
foundation when there was no waves right
you know now we we created this and it
was awesome and they took it to the next
level
and then after Jeff Phillips did that
slowly like with extreme games and all
these other competitions Byrne came back
[ __ ] yeah vert came back and it came
back strong cuz it was like a whole
section for it vert competition and then
the street competition and then that's
just caliber is all over the wall that
the vert ramp halfpipe see and because
before it was just Burton's is real
skating now is the big thing there were
the rock and roll stars of scape you
were skinning a Tony Hawk back then you
were flying bro yeah you didn't have to
be skinny there is dudes that are short
and stoppages all over their body did
you have in it were there any like in
we're not in fighting or like looking
down on each other for different skill
like at that level because at that level
this is like what third generation
probably you're you're thinking about
professional you think about money
endorsements and all that stuff it's a
little more of a business side of it was
there anything like wait you know people
trying to kick you out of the game or it
was yeah no that's a good question that
yeah I'm glad that you brought that up
what happened for me is I started to
lose my love for skateboarding when it
started to be more of a business where I
had dudes that didn't even skateboard
had no idea about it but were very smart
business
and telling me how to skate what tricks
I need to do like what I had to jump
down who I had to talk to and that like
I didn't know about that side of it and
I I believe that it kind of uh it
definitely discouraged me but it also
like I said made me start losing my love
for skateboarding it made me not take it
seriously that's like what you found in
love with the freedom no one liked it
was yeah it was something that I was
gonna do whether I was paid or not and
then it got to the point where now it
was a now you're it's an industry and
you're getting paid for it so that was
just a plus and then you got hurt yeah I
got I well I just got older the wear and
tear that my back took skateboard that
was like one accident was like over
though it was over time and that little
people already like they're prone
especially with my dwarfism which is
called achondroplasia they're prone to
having like bad lower backs even if you
don't do sports or so you got to really
take care of yourself and the wear and
tear that my back took through it
definitely didn't help and then I got in
a really bad car accident but my
skateboard career was already done in a
sense like I was saying before it's when
you're a kid you know you you're having
so much fun that you never want it to
end but you never think it's gonna that
what you knew it was over
oh yeah that because of the the the
doctor was just straight-up with me it's
like you're you're never gonna be able
to straight to skate again and that was
just such up from being like 29 years
old and hearing that and and it being
something that you did your whole entire
life you didn't I didn't know anything
else
brutal savor that last day yeah I did I
did I went to college for like a like a
semester you know and then there was
like college or becoming a pro
skateboarder and traveling the world
I'll take that one yeah good choice so
and but now it's like what with acting
like what happened was a it was like a
different passion that not necessarily
fell on my lap but IIIi it was something
where a manager saw me and he's like hey
I see some potential you got like the
the ryf is
you got the right attitude we got you
got an edge let's would you ever
consider this and then slowly I started
transitioning to that but it was hard it
was both and I you know I I didn't like
it at first I just didn't want to be
emotionally vulnerable and show people
like how I truly feel and cry and dabeh
you know I it took something that had to
grow it like grow on me what was your
first role or what was the first thing
that you consider your first the first
thing I did or I I did like a bunch of
like little kind of sketch comedy things
I wasn't really funny you know it was
more like a thing of like using like my
size to my advantage of of like it was
always a high-contrast thing and I'm not
saying it's not no more but so I always
kind of like I didn't believe what I was
doing and then I I booked this job it
was just a music video so John
Mellencamp music video and they just
hired me because of my look they wanted
a small dude a dwarf little person that
was like in this early early 30s maybe
late 20s kind of uh and to play this
role in this town of being like this
this guy that's trying to make it and
falls in love with an average-sized girl
and everybody in the town doesn't agree
with it and so it was like a reverse on
racism thing the cherry bomb no it was
called walk tall and so and at the end
the dude that the dude gets the girl
they fall in love and they ride off into
the sunset together and I I watched that
music video and we were acting the whole
time we were really doing dialogue to
each other but it's just it's it shot
like a montage and just I watched it and
I was like I didn't I never saw myself
like that and it was just so powerful
and effective and just seeing like the
the reaction that like other people got
from it like close friends that grew up
with me girls you know they were crying
and going oh my god I can't believe this
is you like holy [ __ ] like so that kind
of slowly made me transition to like be
something like like maybe this is
something that like I
could pursue and so I slowly did but
with acting it's so unstable it's it's
something that you you commit all the
way to order you don't and luckily I met
the right people I built the right
relationships I had the right managers
that helped me catapult to the next
level and I took it so serious that I
gave up a lot of things that I love just
to know that I gave it a hundred percent
to to this to this path this journey and
for some people you know it happens like
that not not for me you know for me I
got a really work on it and work and
work and it's like ups and downs and but
then at the end I feel like I I I it's
building up my confidence it's making me
more experienced more seasonal and just
making me ready for that perfect
opportunity and I believe I've had some
and I thank people like Rob Zombie for
you know giving me that chance because
it it he introduced me and do the tool
world that I never knew it like existed
I knew about the horror world yeah but I
didn't know it was like there's a horror
convention in every city and the fans
how much they loved it and you can make
money off of it and you can build
there's a build your brand yeah exactly
so it was it was a whole different world
it was just like skateboarding but it's
a different world you know and these
fans are loyal they love you they love
or and they you you state you keep going
because of them you're the killer guard
in the movie I always play a killer
except in the last one yes I the first
movie I did was with Rob Zombie I played
a Nazi Hitler clown that spoke Spanish
which was completely [ __ ] up but it's
Rob Zombie so what do you expect
and then the next movie a lot of
freedoms like oh yeah I don't even know
what I'm saying yeah he's just like do
that again what did you say I'm like I
said something really
yeah and and so he trusts you as an
actor to do what he hired you to do and
I was the only person that actually
auditioned for that movie so all the
other actors are people that he's worked
with before that he trusts that he loves
and he can count on to bring these
characters to life and then with the the
last movie that I just did for him which
comes out next week on month art down
Monday three from hell it's uh the
follow-up to his Devil's reject me and
oh it's gonna be [ __ ] insane
my character is completely different and
I it wasn't a phone call I got it was an
email going hey it's movie time again
let's uh I wrote a part for you and my
my movie and my follow-up to the Devil's
Rejects I'm not sure if you're familiar
with it but I got a joke part for you
he's completely opposite of your last
character let's see what you can do with
it are you down I'm like [ __ ] yeah I'm
like this this is awesome this is all
you ever want for Peter like yeah think
outside the box and write things for you
and yeah think about you when they're
making it yeah and so that to me was
just like so heartfelt and just an honor
I'm like yeah let's do it itself awesome
that's how I got three from Hell and
we're kind of going from there but then
we J there's an old actor right at bald
yeah Captain Spaulding but what's the
name of your life said hey dude that
fool been in a hundred and something
moving horror movies right yes I saw one
with him and Pam Grier it's a B movie
where he there's an island and all the
women are in cages like they're all
bosom women broke seventies style they
were showing
satting ass and titties dawg but Pam
Grier is like loose and he's there like
a like are they Amazonian yes a man and
he's playing like this rebel from
another country but they're slapping
women dong it's very no sexist movie but
that guy over here in a lot of horror
movies B movies
he's been around bro like he's a
character actor and he wants love with
Rob Zombie now I realize he was in that
movie too
yeah I unfortunately I didn't get to do
my scenes with him or work with him but
I heard the stuff he did it wasn't
legends bro yeah I am in the horror
problems let me pick the right people
bro because that guy is known in the
horror
he's got following like even if there's
like the the Rob Zombie horf he has more
following and then there's just a horror
fans my his his like fans are so loyal
and it's they they like anything he does
and and he he makes movies for the fans
he doesn't make them for the mainstream
[ __ ] the industry [ __ ] the mainstream he
makes them for the fans and that's one
of the things that's so loyal about him
so excited about the movie coming up
yeah I'm excited about that one and then
never like in the history like this is
like a good time for me in a sense that
I have two movies coming out
back-to-back like one on Monday and one
on Tuesday and that that doesn't happen
you know at least not to me so I'm very
excited to promote these movies and be a
part of this genre that has been so
giving to me you know and accepted me so
you take what you get and you make the
best out of it and you do your best so
I'm happy about that
hell yeah what's up Johnny over there
all quiet man no good air to me
I'm not like in the horror movies could
we still scare me yeah I still get
nightmares they don't scare you like you
know oh yeah you're a weirdo
The Devil's Rejects scared like I saw
the trailer Hills Have Eyes yeah that
that was really scary too oh it's too
thin you guys I mean like child playing
lesser that I would like to work with
his name is aster something he's a great
director I wish I knew his name but he
made the movie hereditary and then he
made this other movie that just came out
called Midsomer Smithson or
and there yeah they're not I mean
hereditary is scary and they're not it's
just they're just kind of like mine Fox
yeah because it's something that could
really happen you know when you watch
something you're like this could really
happen even like the purge it's not
scary but you're like this could really
happen and I think I lost all yeah I
would be [ __ ] I'm like where am I
gonna go Yahoo Am I I'm just like this
tell me now who y'all kickin it with one
some fool man what's your Instagram and
Twitter people can find you it is follow
this movie poncho Moeller pee poncho
molar P mu mo le are mo er yeah and you
can also follow the the candy corn movie
that comes out on September 6 17th and
they'll be out on VOD it'll be out on
Amazon Prime and blu-ray and that's
gonna be awesome movie it's it's it's
Club it's the perfect Halloween treat I
feel that you can rent it with your
girlfriend and watch it and be
completely stoked and scared at the same
time you might even get some at the end
yeah I know
you knew it then why'd you ask it's uh
it's uh never for you know I never
forget a face or a new skateboard yeah I
did something like I I said I did a
couple of them and it was a long no it
was almost 20 years old it was over yeah
it wasn't over I was at my peak at the
time that's another thing on my lap I
gave the deck
guys this you betcha following your lap
but this is the time you're meeting just
crazy [ __ ] everywhere parties
are yeah it wasn't always a guy like
that I grow a Tony I'm a producer for
Shane's world I just [ __ ] love your
work I think you'd be perfect for the
part
chiton kind of like that and I heard of
Shane's role before so it's fun that you
bring
lady it was it was for skateboarding
there's uh there's conventions all over
the place for like there's two
conventions a year for these conventions
you got like all the skateboard
companies there as well as all the
sunglass companies they're like black
flies and just different like clothing
companies and they're they all like
advertise these women these like these
girls that like comment like and take
the pictures to advertise their band
brand and a lot of them are porn stars
and they're who are the porn stars
walking around with their [ __ ] agents
and so it's one of those things that is
like hey I like your look you know would
you ever consider this this is a girl
that you'd be [ __ ] or whatever you
know like me you know and it's like I'm
young I'm stupid you know and I'm just
like I I don't know what I I don't know
what to say it's and I'm just like I
don't know let me think about it and I
have your card I'll call you and I think
about it and you know you're you you
just make a choice and and it was
something that I did and I tried it out
a few times and then I was like you know
what this isn't for me you know I I am
NOT that I wasn't good at it condom with
no condom back then
well yeah you don't have you that's the
one of the good things about porn that
I'm you know but I'm going to point out
it yester
at least for me like everyone had to be
tested it's called the PCR screening mmm
DNA screening test and you get tested
and it's for people that are doing porn
constantly they're getting tested every
month or every couple weeks especially
if they work a lot and it test you
whether you contracted anything within
the last five days you know so you you
and and you do it before you're gonna
shoot and and so I I was like okay like
I'll do it and yeah like I said I ate I
did it it was like something that was
like I don't know if this is something I
would want to do and it was such a weird
transition for skateboarding the
half-life or you want the full
you know like you take what what you get
and you make the best out of it you
embrace it but as far as for for little
people or a little dude doing it it was
never gonna be something real it was
always gonna be a gimmick yeah it was
always gonna be a no vanish yeah a
novelty and so it wasn't it was a it
just wasn't something that I was gonna
willing to like yeah yeah yeah react to
that they feel sorry for you again you
guys are my boy I will do some bad tank
in a short amount of time
literally and it'll be right but you're
here now bro you know what I don't know
how old you are but when you're when
you're like you know you're successful
you're into movies but now at a
different age now and more mature you
feel happy man if this should happen
into you like back then you feel happy
back there but now you really have to
because you know what I'm building
something for the future back to you
living in a [ __ ] moment oh yeah yeah
we're right I was always living in a
moment and I still am but it's it's
definitely even like with with acting
and going to school for it and going to
classes and stuff it's like I I'm like I
want to absorb all I'm absorbing all
this and I'm like studying and I'm like
you know like getting better at it and
I'm like where was this mentality when I
was in school yes like but it happened
to me like older so I accept it I'm
happy about that
for that more you did a dirty movie with
any lines
yeah I'm the director no no no this is a
line and I don't know when he's gonna be
upset at me for saying this but I
remember one line humans yeah I got many
is this dick ain't gonna suck itself go
I don't have my stage fright okay now we
wanna hook it with barrio girls by the
way that podcasts are you still doing
that you want to do it no regrets I have
10-foot tall
I started bangbros grow here in Pacoima
come on down don't you owe me
yeah it's Pancho molar P PA n CH o mo le
R & R is P not like PP e nothing to do
with poor nothing organization social
gotta go put it in your molar Vegas this
Friday master Thibaut 13 Treasure Island
casino I already told you guys please
show up I did eight hours I did eight
hours of press man I got up at 6:00 in
the morning and then like later in bed
and still meet down at 7:05 we left
seven and
and then I depressed I went to TV where
mice tracksuit took up my tracksuit I
was parking then I pressed I was
starving like Marvin
I wanna Poncho's vegan they change
location the food's still good we'll
just not enough for me I want to eat
more food but I can't wait to get there
las vegas judge Ryland order room
service bro an order for it comes a
little coffee pot ah I love la need to
Sacramento September 14 I will get the
crest theater the Sacramento man what's
up man haven't been doing years
cobblestone are being Cabazon morongo
casino this show man start early man
it's already sold out 6 p.m. at 6:00
6:00 p.m. that son of to be out DC area
September 26 the route and 21st the
return of Johnny rakia people 20 and
21st Arlington draft hours we're gonna
be the two days
for shows El Paso Texas okay man this is
where it gets tough I'm gonna be at the
Plaza theater September 27 Pro see some
of the proceeds of those tickets you buy
the proceeds will go to El Paso
Community Fund the Oh pastor Community
Fund and I put to help out the people of
the victims or anybody involved in what
happened at that Walmart in the shooting
the massacre but that coward that white
coward anyway so DC that'll be you know
Paso Texas September 27 Plaza theater
I'm afraid to go to Walmart now I'm
quite a target no shoot it went to
Walmart you should go to Target little
bit a good advert that'll be a good at
for target hey come shock will come shop
with us here you won't be a target huh
ahead of my time bro SuperSonics could
spend that way
what he meant by that buddies nothing
against even though you know he was
upset that they hadn't waiting in a
green room for four hours and he kept
getting bombed for the interview so he
was losing his mind by that time to the
controller
he fired me before he went inside done
it he fired supersonic before the show
is gonna be at the Mandalay Bay Los
Angeles California
October 4th Microsoft bro you know you
get a lot of likes bro here now you know
corporate was in the back you know it's
under El Paso oh yeah Corpus Christi
Texas September 28th Salina auditorium
American Bank Center be there Mac
Kostabi he's gonna be there oh I can't
wait so did he ever I don't know oh you
know you get the most likes man nowadays
it's by over writing something that no
that's normal to everybody else
now you override it like you you write
add stuff so that has nothing to do with
anything like disguise the water just
squirt right here just did the squirt
it's just water I got from me to beat
you or whatever it is right and I mean
if he has me by a peasant you know
nobody's a fascist you know normally of
not somewhat like a homeless a peasant
no no I'm gonna build it somewhere
they're playing a little flute lesson
when they play the malls you know she's
gonna baby her back she should wear
multiple colors she like a [ __ ]
mountain BAM no if you have UT bro
she just having me tea cuz she started T
to the hikers on the way there whatever
so I
whatever was anyways a normal person
like him and I were right
I had to the mazing tea on his mountain
his lady was written colors boom anyway
that's it but someone like Jada Pinkett
wrong or someone else who's a [ __ ]
YouTube sensation or influenced
marriages well yeah he gave me life
today that's it let me tell you when I
tell you that this tea brought new
visions into my world that were never
there before there before I mean
whenever woman looking in her eyes I see
how God had worked with her and and I
see the struggle that she lives in life
and I relay into my life how penny I
live my life compared to this rich and
down woman here but this goes off
forever broke out of my future in their
eyes there you go everybody neverending
story over here so that's something bro
the heavenly gates opened up my
consciousness I mean it was usually
wills dick that gave me life but this
water is he teased me the [ __ ] up that's
why I wait little but do not talk about
wills dick will be in my speeches this
is because that takes away my feminine
power yes first stop of minutes
oh no jada jada don't put a hand up
energy I saw a picture of her with a
lion brother no more lying when I saw
the power and the courage and the
confidence of this beautiful man-made
beast saw the footprints in his paws his
child out of the Jeep Jada I thought
about what what footprints a mile deep
in this earth
it's something about his per yeah bro
strong our swear to god bro I can that
right like that
Oh Wendy baby used to riding for me
reckless doing in Spanish but I would
just to write blah blahs let them let me
to blog like dictating their somebody
yeah someone like that did like
something on Instagram it would get
millions and so we will have to do it
not you back to your point like someone
new actor and you actor tress they're
working on your movie oh man when I was
given the opportunity to wear was wrong
Dom be up and she's gonna lie first of
all she'll leave this but I had to go
google him first
I'm 20 would I've always wanted a work
we're done Rob Zombie's since I was born
I saw Rob Zombie at [ __ ] it up at was it
twins it evil tour with Marilyn Manson
okay maybe with Kid Rock we lose about
Nicaraguan heroes but they don't blow it
90s that's why Tommy that's why we're
skating you being a vegan like white
zombie yeah blow up yeah we will never
forget go through a Britney Spears stage
right here you just gotta find yourself
some time buncha when I was out I'm
saying that because
when I went to I went to his interview
on top with a gap and we're all sitting
there in everybody huh so what you been
up to the last six months
anybody got to be out I was like nervous
bugs you've already heard everybody else
yeah I put on at the top they're mad
I knew it again higher since I'm making
[ __ ] up so those are food a little edge
on you bro had a backpack in the asset
will you've been doing while the last
week smothering backpacking through
Europe and I was life experience in the
Lewis and Clark thank you LS the large
for bringing a car 54 Bel Air everybody
happy belated birthday to Big Boy boy
they don't know what's up man he could
bag from he's gonna bag you bro cuz I'm
we're bagging on everybody I bagged on a
cruise I call that full little little
chuckle little [ __ ] Shan Shan Shan
Shan Shan's
then I call Big Boy red skull bro then
he had a good one
we're so full partial year any last
words bro for your fans
we're gonna go look for that video right
now no no no don't do that go uh go
watch three from hell that comes out on
September 7 September 7th 16th it will
be out of limited theatres on fathom
events you can get your tickets on the
17th 16 17th and 18th and go watch candy
corn that comes out next perfect
Halloween treat it will be out on the
17th on Tuesday it will be out on VOD
blu-ray and Amazon Prime you guys are
gonna love it this Monday so what's up
with the legend of you know what unless
I say [ __ ] told him the whole story
he was somebody he was what is this
memory they have a way the sponsor stuff
but nobody in Spanish padrino's they
have padrino's for everything a party
knows further beers but readers for the
food and then I go through the look
whatever give a tag your Philippe there
was about three no for their tags cuz he
would like whenever the crowd would go
silent or they weren't listening he's
off a bit I mean that was like kind of
like let's get back on task he should
wear a poncho on stage of her so haters
rapping kasam a father they what type
baby we're a [ __ ] sudhir in belly
mana and he bob art you know whites were
sued because turn up it were the SUNY
media they look like they work for prime
America hardcore ghetto but what didn't
matter good room Gilbert burritos in
that truck so you remember VFW shout out
to the vsw in Wilmington PCH PCH and now
I don't know the other Street man but
damn there's some good ass time with a
bunch of the guys thought boule movies
brought in your movie but it's gonna be
there brother for reals
that's how you know bro leg like the
streets [ __ ] with you bro and a [ __ ]
bullet already bro
ain't nobody bootlegging a movie bro
with our star is born dog know they're
bootlegging the fun stuff
[ __ ] your horror movie comedy hell yeah
man what was the scare before he going
man what was your worst horrible with
them they scared the [ __ ] out of you
when I I when I first moved to the
state's when I moved to Hawaii like
coming from Chile barely knowing any
English the scariest movie I had a
babysitter we called her name was anti
baby she became like my second mom
because my mom had to work so much that
I start I started living there a little
and her her son we became good friends
and and then and then his sisters we all
and we watched Exorcist
[ __ ] yeah like seven years old on Kota
could like I don't know it was Evan
that's too young ya know and I just
didn't like the demonic voice and the
mouth for cool bro and the girl that was
bang and she's doing with the Chris that
was Christ compels
[ __ ] with maze yeah that's hardcore man
you never heard about masturbation first
of all I know like being brainwashed and
I remember asking about Holly I remember
my mom after Exorcist and I said can
people really get possessed and she said
only in third-world countries
scary has GUI one time and it was just a
woman in the island and she got raped by
five dudes in Ireland but then she kills
all of Oh horrible girl and it's a real
scary by spirit him in the ass dog it
was hardcore I see the movement myself
on you right now bro
an eye for an eye oh man woman gets
ribbon I didn't kill everybody movie
woman gets raped it kills everybody on
the island with King Kong movie
premonition and yeah I know it's called
King dong called ding dong yeah King
Kong
I don't know man but it's a hardcore
movie this is a b-movie kimono 1780s
[ __ ] hardcore man but the most
hardcore boy I ever saw was one with
[ __ ] Antonio Banderas I think Marco or
Javier Bardem horror movie anus skin
skin skin skin the skin I'm in this guy
in is friend rape totally rape I want to
walk ahead all right whoo why do they
die yeah
but anyway man that is totally story bro
it's like the total history movie is
like
and that this guy went all this trouble
with plastic surgeon all those it's like
a long torture to rape this torture this
guy who raped oh you told me about it
yeah yeah that's creepy creepy huh
go watch your brother's game I don't
make nobody you know what's a really
like [ __ ] up movie - did you guys ever
see the human centipede yeah I got to do
real the millipede no yeah yeah
basically and I couldn't imagine how
they made a part - I don't really
remember how the first one that is but
it was just like yeah how you kid like
they like they literally like took the
teeth off to attach them by their gums
to someone's [ __ ] taped it so it yes
sewed it together like you and then like
it everyone that they wanted to be done
or the crazy like doctor like like Angel
of Death like German doctor that's just
like a pet I'm sorry they kept it yeah
he made it he wanted to make them all
dogs - oh [ __ ] eat my cousin she took me
to see a horrible wound I was like your
age 9 or 8 it was called Seuss pedia and
that [ __ ] was scary dog I mean
like a Mexican harm roof or Kyra numeral
of Mexican or English or Spanish or
Italian from the poachers yeah it was
[ __ ] scary dog [ __ ] that I don't
really like their movie do I remind him
scary movies or anything scary until
last year we start going to these horror
things we went to like manna Valley
no he went to the universal what do you
call that the Horror Nights
yeah horn horn horn ice we went there
last year and then we went to that one
at Queen Mary on the boat yeah wait I
just decided like after two things we
went to it that when I was like I think
I'm tired of being scared jump scares I
can't it hurts my body physically I feel
like like moaning I thought you liked
the actors yeah
still like you know my thought is that
my thought is that somebody some [ __ ]
because there's always an [ __ ] and
it's dark some [ __ ] gonna stick
around and I do extra scaring off that
you know that's my fear is that a real
person is gonna be there and mess things
up you know want to mess around with you
I throw a girl at a monster once we're
at those things that are scared night
through her what's up fool man take
everybody who live off thirty people
like 89 89 89 no it's like the house of
a left alright then I checked that one
now house on the left
yeah my that movie scary [ __ ] up to
that movie with where it's a book to
that with a guy who buries that girl
onto the ground
buried alive and she writes all Angela's
bone I mean a lovely bones lovely bone
man that wasn't really a horror movie
with us just disturbing pedophile oh
yeah like the guy
you want to know when he won the award
he got it he's like yeah I'm a jinnah
quitting the award for like playing the
best killer pedophile you know yeah that
movie happy happy eyes happiness
yeah that's a good movie and it was an
indie movie it's um what's his face I
can't think of a directory it's Todd
Solondz the guy made welcome to the
dollhouse and uh a couple of the movies
but he made this one and it was
something cold yeah
he molested him further sleepovers
brought his son before the rest of his
ass he goes
would you molest me too that was crying
the scene the the movie is just he's
such a great actor that kicks up it was
Julie who are you know it just seems
like he didn't get much after that he
the guy who plays the pedophile yeah
Rose but not Academy Award there's like
a fine line when you're kind of gonna
attack a role like that like it's you
got to be ready like to be able to speak
well afterwards or just kind of well
there was notice you know the better
about it and like I like I like I like
you're doing research Lord and it you
know the pervert is there putting that
pervert it's that guy from planes to
automobiles the one that goes Billy that
comes in the truck at pixel take fireman
um my wives go pick you catch your back
she has seven kids they all come out
sideways yeah when you were where you
were you when you were doing that thing
and you went that made me think of
Silence of the Lambs yeah exactly
very nice crazy ii largely killed that
guy though yeah okay
made him kill himself or worse up oh
well sick be careful to go the realtor
is dirty broken Lisa
Parcher right here had a good time